Actor Aaron Eckhart: We're all riddled by fear and doubt and
and we all have dreams we talk ourselves
out of those dreams we like to see
people who have been on the top and have
fallen down
fallen from grace and then picking
themselves back up I always say there's
no such thing as second chances you get
as many chances as you want in this
world it's how you present yourself to
the world that gives you the second
chance you can continually reinvent
yourself but you've got to do it. Actor Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: I've
never had a plan B for some reason I'm
very stupid I've always had a I guess a
very unrealistic belief that it would
work out but it did. Actor Lakeith Stanfield: Half of it was just
trying to hustle up money to get down
and get up on the train and some of it
was my parents they were helping me
every now and again take me whenever you
know whatever my bit my bugging them
sort of hit it's pretty like fine again
for what because when you're auditioning
you begin you don't realize how much
rejections involved in it so you get
rejected 20 30 times you're like what am
I still doing this for obviously it's
not gonna work and it was so much work
for us to get down there that they were
just like this is becoming more of an
expense than anything and so I had to
figure out ways to get them to get down
there on my own after a while and I
missed a lot of auditions because I
couldn't make it but you know and that
sucked that was a hard time cuz I hated
missing them
I'd rather get rejected and then to miss
it you know just knowing that I really
love this job and and knowing that I'm
grateful for it it's something that I
want to do for a very long time so I'm
mindful of it and I think that I kind of
try to be thoughtful about it and and I
mean I think that's it and also just
having a level of perseverance and
always keeping your chin up you know I
think with any job or any career you
know you're always going to have an ebb
and flow and it's gonna be tough some
days and it's gonna be great others and
I just think that if you really love
what you do then you just keep moving
forward so you know just staying
couraged yeah show up that's the hardest
thing I mean there's a lot of people
that never get to that first audition
scam cuz it's hard to get to that first
yeah mm-hmm
you show up you do your best and you
just always try to keep getting better
and the rest of its kind of out of your
hands you know we know what I want to be
an actor I think when I when I decided
I'd rather said how much movies and go
to get University so there's something
in this and I really wanted to be it
when I couldn't you know you you realize
that you really want to be an actor when
you you can't quite get there on
auditions you're not quite getting a job
you just wanted you can feel it I want
to get in that door because the
boogeyman it's bigger than you you don't
you don't fight back you don't do
nothing you don't buy this tow you don't
do nothing
you just talk about the size of the book
in the hand how long he's been on your
neck the color of the boogeyman the
boogeyman system or the boogie Mans how
can you say the order of his breath you
can describe every aspect of the
boogeyman
for the rest of your damn life or you
can buy this tub now yeah I'm gonna kill
with you by this - but toes are
sensitive there's gonna be some movement
well he needs a little bit a little bit
but you're not gonna bite well that's
your definition of your possibilities in
life I can't bite because the boogeyman
so big and I'm so weak goodbye shit
sorry not me never just keep working
hard keep workers the struggle never
stops I mean I'm in movies and
television and I still you know huh so
and try to get the next job and try to
figure I never know what's coming up now
and you know you're on this train and
you just don't know when it's gonna stop
and the hustle never stops so I feel
like it's part of it it's part of what
makes us strong and makes us that actor
do you know it makes it all worth it at
the end but I honestly feel like just
never give up whether it's acting or
anything in your life you just don't
give up there's times I've had times
where I've had to like you know I've got
an emotional about losing something or
not something not going through the way
I wanted it to but you have to keep on
like there's there is no looking back
you know there's yeah there's things
that hurt and it kind of a sad by the
same time you do try to find that
somewhere else you just got to keep
moving forward it's interesting because
tonight for example I am inviting
friends who got off the Hollywood dream
bus with me could never necessarily were
able to execute anything you know it's
interesting they'll be at the screening
tonight for this film and and it's one
of those things where we don't have the
same level of in common conversation
that we once had because life has
happened for me differently and I had to
really check in with myself in terms of
the team personality and me thought that
and I've always been a part of sports
that everybody that got off the dream
bus with me and what I mean by that is
around the same month that you get off
the dream bus and you come to LA or New
York to make things happen you get a
collective of friends and y'all start to
run an audition circuit and slowly
certain people's pace slows down and
others keep going and my big thing
always to those people I'm inviting the
night and to as you said those that are
aspiring actors my wisdom and advice was
always first and foremost if you can
wake up without wanting to do this you
have one morning where you wake up and
go I don't really want to do this I
would say get out because it's way too
difficult somebody could ask me are
there moments of that being defined as
being discouraged and I would go know
everybody's discouraged you everybody
calls home and goes I don't know if you
know I should become a rocket scientist
if I should as a woman continue in this
world of men and corporate spectrums or
law or medicine or what-have-you
people will all get discouraged
including myself and asking mom and dad
if I should come back home very early in
my journey out here but I think in terms
of the representation part I decided to
not and this is really my wisdom to them
to not really worry about it
my thought was you know if it's looked
if it looked like it was easier for me
than it was it was because I really
pressed hard at the craft the work the
acting classes making sure that I was in
martial arts if I could add that to the
repertoire box or the box of tools that
I could dig into if I needed to work on
the piano because one day I could play a
character where I played the piano just
work on the craft and don't necessarily
worry about the representation they will
it'll find you the right agent will find
you the right manager the right put now
am i struggling in terms of wanting even
bigger out of my career while there's
people not where I'm at going you look
like you made it I don't know what make
it is you know I'm satisfied I'm so
humble and thankful to God that I'm
where I'm at but there's always more and
so if you focus on the more being
attained by you making sure that you do
more for yourself then I don't
necessarily think the representation
should matter
again they definitely will always find
you well I'd say you follow your dreams
you know follow your instincts
this was that still Adler said in order
to be in this business you need the oh
is that the the soul of a rose and the
hide of a rhinoceros so that's kind of
sums it all up for you know it's you
know you're trying to protect that
creative part of you by dealing with a
lot of BS every day and and sometimes
you get to express that part of you
that's that you want and the reason
you've got in this business in the first
place so I think people should just
follow their dreams and not be afraid of
failing and trying again and and you
know I mean great actors they look at
Morgan Freeman for instance ran into him
not too long ago great guy I mean nobody
know who he was until he was about 50 or
55 years old right he'd done all of
these movies and suddenly he was in the
Driving Miss Daisy
so there's a guy who probably had to
deal with a lot of rejection and failure
and now he's you know one of the
greatest actors in the country so in the
world
so you see don't give up that's the main
thing don't give up I think with Vinnie
Vinnie had his family support Vinnie
also his sport was boxing my sport was
baseball baseball was something that you
know I remember even in high school I
was doing as a freshman I would be the
guy going to two days with the seniors
ROG I'd go to high school at a you know
five thirty and run laps and do all that
stuff like if I had the talent in
baseball that's something I would have
given everything to I think sports for
me just the discipline and kind of the
you know the ethics of the games it was
something that I really associated with
there's a combination of so many things
also luck it really really does but you
do have to come prepared during those
lucky moments and so and don't be afraid
to grow yeah and also when you've driven
for the right reasons I think it's very
clear the actors that are doing what
they do for sheer passion and love for
what they do I know that's our case and
I think it's very clear when you walk in
a room I think there's no BS if what you
know it's yeah like there's only so much
you can pretend and and there's so much
front you can can come into a room with
at the end of the day it's it's the core
of you that matters it's it's your it's
your talent that gets you further so
lock and all these things yes you have
an opportunity and it's what you you
come to the table with and if you come
to the table with the right things the
right people will notice mm-hmm there
you go wow that was great
Doug done Oh drop the mic that's great
my grandfather was the only positive
voice he was the only you can do it that
I got like that
there was not for my career many friends
weren't it's a tough business you know
but my grandfather was like no you can
do it I know you can do it I just needed
to hear it Denis Tony believed in me
that was the one voice I feel like
everybody has another life and it's
really I call it the life of your dream
you know your dream has a reality that
most people kind of separate from their
president but I like to say that my
dream is my now the first coat and the
first law of shedding is empowering your
inner self you know that acting is a
gift that is not given by man home so we
just have to really improve it your your
inner image opposed to your outer one my
month of combating moping is basically
staying staying grounded and making sure
and remembering that I'm really the one
that's tearing my shift is not a movie
is not people but I'm the one that's
controlling my joy and happiness for me
I don't know about you but there's a lot
of reasons that go into well I might
I've turned down good parts before or
I've auditioned for movies really that
where I should have tried harder to get
over something but I don't usually
regret it because wherever I was in my
life at that point that's why I wasn't
interested in that role just that wasn't
I mean I've read a script before for
example I thought was just terrible and
then I saw the movie the movie was great
it was obvious that I didn't understand
the script yes I was obviously the wrong
actor because I didn't get it yeah I
mean it's happened to me to just say no
to films that end up being successful or
they act to end up but when I turned
down my gun show I was like I just I
hadn't heard of Steven Spielberg
I hadn't heard of Lincoln I was weird
why are they talking funny it was like
no I mean regrets are just like when you
know I'm not a person that's big on
regrets like I'm like moving forward and
I'm actually
in a way like the things I said no to
brought a certain famed people so but in
a way kind of I know my life my path was
pretty much meant to go into a direction
of writing and directing and and I think
if it did I didn't make the choices of
maybe more like successful big films and
stuff it's also maybe because I was like
looking for what I really want to do is
my life which I found so you know I I
have no regrets
I have zero so I'm exactly where I want
to be and I know that's crazy to say
that right but it's true I am where I
want to be exactly and I'm looking
forward to doing more of that I think
it's being able to find your happiness
during the times that you're not working
you know so much of being an actor is is
looking for work
it's an inordinate disproportionate
percentage of time that you're looking
for work as opposed to actually being on
set being employed earning money all of
that sort of stuff and it's critical
that you can find happiness in life
aside from the infrequent successes that
you know you get as an actor and it took
me a long time to learn that you know
you obviously have to find within
yourself and then creating you know your
your support base whether it's your
family your friends around you and get
your happiness from that and then
everything else that comes into your
life with with acting is icing on the
cake you got a little process you know
the process and you know I think be okay
for the most part and the square of the
square one thing it's a you know you're
constantly and yes it's always a
struggle I think you know there's
there's different forms the challenges
reinvent themselves the obstacles and
you try to try to develop the foresight
to be able to see those things come in
but I'm when I get back to square one
it's it's you know you embrace it and
then you work diligently and extra hard
to you know to get ahead you know in
your craft
auditions or whatever it is you're doing
writing directing the early success
wasn't really success I would say hi I
wouldn't really call it early success I
it was I don't even view it that way I
view it as six years of no one wanting
my stuff and it was you know some random
person who was very kind was interested
in a script but it wasn't as if it was
all of a sudden I made it and it's
happening now so it really was a six
seven year journey to selling my first
project which was recount and why I
didn't give up I think is because I had
something to say and I loved writing
these scripts and they were important to
me and I loved working on stories and it
just was artistically extremely
fulfilling where my acting career was
very frustrating and sometimes I and I
worked I didn't really seem worked on
some terrific shows that I'm really
proud of but I wasn't actually getting
to act very much so even when you're
working you know I would do episodes of
Gilmore Girls and I would do four
episodes of season and I would work on
it a day or two and that would be one of
my only jobs for six months so it's
really about seven days on set over a
six month period so what am i doing the
rest of the time I'm auditioning and
trying to get new jobs but that's an
hour a day maybe so really it was it was
a creative outlet for me of taking my
creative energy and putting it into
something where I can actually just go
do it
where as an actor you have to be picked
to go do it and then you rarely get
picked so I just found it fulfilling but
I also was getting rejected and left and
right script after script and agents
managers production company everyone
didn't want my work for six seven years
and I think I got to a point where I
asked myself this is not going well what
are you what do you want from this what
what are you doing and I sort of I asked
myself would I and it's one of the key
questions in the movie would I do this
for the rest of my life if I got nothing
in return
and I thought yeah I would and then I
just kept writing and then eventually it
wasn't as if six months later crack the
champagne it was maybe three years later
that I sold recount as a pitch to HBO
and then just kind of went on from there
but there was a certain peace in knowing
that it wasn't about it wasn't about
selling something or success even though
I really wanted it I wasn't and what you
know wasn't a kumbaya moment but there
was a peace in knowing that well
whatever happens you just keep writing
so just keep writing and that's what I
did just do what's in front of you sort
of you know you know it's gotten easier
over the years I don't I I try not to
travel to too often because I do have a
little one also and you know it's all
it's all good is what I always tell
myself it's all you know and it all gets
done I just feel blessed about it that I
continue to work and that jobs come my
way and and and different and
interesting kind of jobs you know I feel
like it keeps getting you know I don't
ascribe to the fact that we as women as
we get older should be sort of
disappearing and so far I've been able
to stay you know viable so and I I maybe
it's sort of like Vinnie Paz I refuse to
believe otherwise you know Vinnie Paz
believed that he would box again
I just believe I'll keep working I guess
you just gotta believe in yourself and
work on your craft and really basically
comes down to your ability to to
entertain people you know I'm on screen
if you if you're in the film business or
a TV business you know so when you get
your shot you got to be ready to take it
and then you got to really go for it at
that point so funny I was talking to my
wife and I was talking to another
another actor the other day and I said
you know be the amount of arrogance that
you have to have
to say I'm gonna go to Hollywood and be
an actor that I'm interesting enough for
people to you know most likely pay to
watch it's kind of off the Richter scale
but you also have to have that level of
I guess belief in yourself to to make
the journey to do this it doesn't come
with a playbook for me it has been like
most actors ups and downs you know you
have some feast you have some famine
hopefully it's a little more feast and
famine and I've been very fortunate in
that way that you know I've been able to
do this for the better part of my adult
life and not have to get a real job but
no it's it's probably nothing like I
imagined it would be when I was getting
on the plane some 30 years ago to come
out here
I got happened I mean I've been doing it
was 25 years I've been working every
year I haven't had any downtime I've
never I mean to worry that you're in
something that's successful that's gonna
hurt you I mean that's the least of my
worries it's usually the other way
around that you do something and you are
that no one will want to see it and I've
been working and every year of doing
Game of Thrones and I hope that if I
choose that I'll continue to be working
there's a sort of attitude that you
write the narrative of your own life and
you sort of can write the narrative of
your own career there are going to be
external circumstances that you don't
control there's jobs that I'm not going
to get offered you know the roles that
Tom Cruise gets offered you know and I
know that and I recognize that even
though sometimes on a couch on a couch I
need to go crazy but you know I I still
think that I have consistently worked
over a period now of almost 20 I mean 18
years 14 years in LA and it's only
because ever since I was a child I said
well this is what I'm gonna do and I
never do
from that and so even if I have a year
where I don't work I will it'll come
back again
you know ya know whether those storms
and as I get older and I know that
they're coming
then I it's easier to weather them the
more that I've been through them yeah I
think it's also just about like having
some control about what projects you
pick and let into your life you know I
think it's a you know navigating that
ship and making sure that you're on a
trajectory that will have the same end
result that you hope and yeah I tried
very hard to only be a part of projects
that you know I think are cool and you
know I think with me we've both been
lucky that way to do things that we
actually would I mean at a point in a
career when we weren't necessarily able
to choose what we were doing we both
have done things that we would choose to
do there's a guy that played football
always comes to mind and he he he got
like he was always around the ball and
he played defense so he would recover
fumbles he'd get a lot of interceptions
and so people when you were to watch him
you would say oh he's lucky he's lucky
you know he's always lucky czaja on the
ball but when I watched him I said no I
think he actually has prepared for these
moments you know and I think it's the
people that prepare for moments that
things actually start to show up for
them you know I was going out a lot of
directors before and Crown Heights came
my way I was just calling directors
writing to them and you know you name
the director I probably reached out to
them and didn't get many returns and
probably got like two from people that
you don't know but you know so it was a
little bit frustrating just trying to I
just wanted to audition for something or
just to let them know that I was acting
and you know at the moment when I
stopped when I got frustrated and I just
stopped us I'm not gonna reach out to
any more directors I'm just going to
keep training it was like a month later
the
Crown Heights came from Matt Ruskin so
it's I think it's it's doing the work I
think it's having the faith and the
passion behind it that sort of leads you
to whatever you're supposed to be doing
you have to have a healthy ego to be in
this business you have to know you're
good in order to succeed in this
business if you don't believe that
you're good you know then then you got
to go do something else because you're
gonna get hit time and time again about
how you look you know you're this you're
that you're too old you're too so you
have to have a thick skin and yeah I I
you know just actually I was periscoping
with somebody in the car before this and
I said I was doing this interview and
this guy goes hey get me into the
business and I said get yourself into
the business because it's hard work you
know he's like I want to be an actor and
I said well unless you are an actor and
you are a hundred and ten percent don't
do it because it's tough again I've had
a long beautiful resume but it's still
hard even to this day I have a movie
coming out next year but also I haven't
worked in almost a year so it's like you
have to be able to sustain yourself
somehow through this business and you
know it's tough so yeah you have to you
have to be obsessive to a healthy degree
you know you don't want to be unhealthy
which is the other way around and
tearing yourself down because as actors
I think we are our own worst enemy you
know it's much easier to be loving and
and and inviting to somebody else but
how are you to you towards yourself and
as actors man all of our our emotions
are on on the level on the skin level
right here they're always accessible so
you know it's a daily I think thing to
remind yourself that you got to love
yourself and you got to push yourself in
this business
and don't become complacent I constantly
relapse and think to myself why am I
doing this because acting is a very
abusive relationship you really have to
know what it is and I'm also not one of
those people I'm one of the rare few who
don't believe that to be an actor it's
like all you need to focus on I actually
think to be an actor you have to have
other sources of happiness other sources
of fulfillment and honestly I think even
other sources of work and then you can
really give yourself to acting because
what makes acting really hard is when
when it gets confused with the career
because once you're relying on acting
for money all of a sudden the
desperation works its way into the
audition room and that you know some
people never figure out how to do that
it's a very difficult career path to
really pursue and to also do it in a way
where you're actually able to enjoy the
acting and not be completely reliant on
the ends whether you succeed or not in
order to be happy because we know that
even you know I work a ton and even then
it's so often a struggle lots ups and
down so I have to remember what it is
and what it means to me and for me at
this point in my life I have a wife I
have a kid I have other sources of
fulfillment and I also have other
sources of income because that's the
only way that I can be happy with acting
because you know throughout your career
you're like you give hundreds of
thousands of doubts even while working
you know I I spoke to Jack Lemmon on a
film that I was doing that he was doing
an app and be working with him really
hard enough
and then um and I asked him I said asked
him about the you know I mean he's a
legend I knew that then when I was in my
20s working with him and I asked him
about how he dealt with the challenges
back in his day you know grandpa was a
contract player so he had work every
week whether he worked or not he was
getting paid and he's like oh my god
things I thought every gig was my last
gig you know that's Jack Lemmon like you
thought every gift so I'm okay I'm okay
when I get really scared or I think I'm
not gonna make it or I got my pills paid
for the most part you know I'm good you
know I'm a mansion but I don't want a
mansion I don't need a mansion
you know to be happy I was not good in
school I tried like hell but I was not
good I was very dyslexic without knowing
yet I think a lot of actors are and it
was a great education for me you know
it's a great way to learn about
something and especially to express it
in a certain way it made it really stick
whatever it was that I was studying my
story about myself is it goes up in
conflict with sort of a public persona
you know almost all the time you know I
I am a public personality and often
times I don't think that what's
projected out there is me but I've come
to accept that is you know somebody that
sort of lives have his life in public I
know that I can't control that version
of myself that story that is being told
by a big collective or through you know
a lot of different outlets it's
certainly contrasts with who I I think I
am but I also have kind of reconciled
myself with that that it's just part of
my life for me the more is dramatic
the more you you ask you ask you have to
use humor to to move on and I grew up
like that I started as a comedian
because you humor for me is a wonderful
weapon and you moved the surest way
between two people when you want to
connect with someone humor is the fast
way to connect so I use you know other
time it's part of my personality and
it's the same for Eric and Olivia the
directors that's why we we love working
and being together because we we we have
that communication with humor and and I
think when you talk about the subject
like immigration or the burnout it's
easier to talk about it with
a bit of humor and they used to say it's
champagne bubbles I would say stay in
school stay diligent go through high
school go through college and try to
look through opportunities after having
sort of learned all you can learn and
situate yourself and be comfortable
before you get into acting know that
you're doing there's something else that
you could be doing no you have a back-up
plan because it's a very difficult tough
game to get into and and it's tough to
maintain even once you're in so it's not
like once just because you booked
something means you're gonna be working
forever so you have to always keep that
hustle up and continue to look for new
avenues and know that if this doesn't
worry I got something else in the back
if that don't worry got something else
have other alternatives as well and
don't focus all your energy on acting
would be one thing boxers are you know
they're they sacrifice dedication
discipline you know I find that I have
that in my own life with my own career
you know it takes a fighter's mentality
to you know to work in this business and
we share that if you really want to be
great at something you know maybe you
can't be the best friend or the best
brother or the best son or the best you
know whenever like it's you know that
quest for greatness it is it's gonna be
a selfish journey but if you look you
only get one chance at this life so if
you really want to give everything to
something then it's going to be yeah it
is gonna be an isolated journey you just
have to be comfortable with you know
other areas of your life being
sacrificed for that you know I have a
good family I've great friends that I've
known since I was like 14 15 I don't
have to worry about how's this guy gonna
screw me over or whatever it's like now
I've known these guys more than half my
life you know I've got a great
professional team of people around me
I've got a good girl like so um I don't
know I got enough things to kind of
still make me feel like myself
there's plenty of narcissism in any
field to go around but yeah
you know I mean I'm not slamming actors
because but we are self-employed it is
you are the the product so you have to
take care of yourself make sure you're
taken care of and and so it's yeah it's
it's a bit spit different courses
narcissism music if you're lucky enough
to I'm very humble in music because I am
NOT a rock star at the moment but when
you get well it's the old adage you
could tell who somebody is not when
they're at the bottom but when they're
on the top and they have the the free
will to do to actually act and that's
when you're at the top you see how
somebody treats people that's who they
are
and Lynn Jones evidently didn't didn't
treat people very well because he's got
to make amends while he's eating Red
Vines chasing no I have experienced
before I don't think it's and perhaps
maybe just it's been there and maybe
someone hasn't said it of course it's a
competitive industry and and we're all
buying for you know the same roles and
the great jobs but I've been fortunate
after work with some great people
particularly Mandy who was wonderful and
there was there is not a competitive
bone in her body she's so supportive and
kind and just such a great teammate
so yeah I haven't you know really had
that experience in the work world I
haven't either I think I've been I've
really lucked out that I haven't
encountered anybody in that regard it's
you know felt they need to be
competitive I feel like the industry
pits us all against one another as women
anyway and there's just there's enough
there's enough room for everybody and
just having faith that like things work
out the way they're supposed to and we
should be there to support and build
each other up you know it's a
competitive world to that we live
nowadays I mean with social media and
everyone's sort of looking at like
someone's seemingly perfect life in the
way they're sort of curating things it's
not necessarily rely that and I think he
remember and just stay in your own lane
and do the work and hopefully good
things come your focus should be your
work just do your work and whatever
happens from that and find any way to do
it like this idea that everybody's going
to come and be famous is like ridiculous
it's are you gonna are you doing the
work because you love the work and you
want to give something then great then
enjoy the hell out of it and if you get
to get a ride like I've had them great
enjoy it but no it's not about an end
result I think there's a danger in
saying a first success because I think
life is just a series of successes and
failures so even in this business I mean
you know success to me is is doing the
job that I got to do in that room you
know whether I get the role or not but
the fact that I I'm able to pull off a
performance and give a performance
because I like to give a performance and
when I audition instead of auditioning
you know I kind of like to do a lot of
the prep work prior like some of the
heavier prep work that most actors might
reserve for after they get the gate if I
have the time I'll I'll tell deeply into
it just that's part of the fun you know
if you want to do a good job but in
regards to making a living gosh you know
you'reyou're it's that struggle you're
juggling jobs you're juggling regular
jobs that let you go to auditions on top
of auditioning you know so it's like
there's a struggle in that and this is
success in that as well so being a
self-starter and not you know trying to
create your own opportunities is really
important I mean that's that's probably
the single biggest piece of advice I
give young actors you know there's so
many mediums available now social
networking
and you know with the internet to create
your own media business card and you
know go out and produce something with
your friends you know put it on YouTube
do something that's gonna show you that
you can then send out and at least say
hey take a look at me you know a lot of
that wasn't available to me when I
started out in kind of the you know the
late 80s so I think the answer your
question to come full circle
yeah it's important to study but you
don't want to be a lifelong student
without jumping into the pool and
actually getting into the you know the
professional aspect I mean it's called
show business there's you know there's a
thing that we used to always say is that
there's there's probably a lot of
waiters out there that are maybe more
accomplished better actors in class than
I am but you know you got to get out
there and and take a swing to get into
business yeah I was all in when I
started you know I don't I can't a half
step I can't I can't just put a little
bit in because then I won't get the
results but then I also don't put
anything into things that I'm not
passionate about or curious about you
know I know from the start if I'm just
in it for other reasons and this was
something that I said from the start I'm
going all-in you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna start training I'm gonna figure
out how people are able to transform in
the way that they do on screen and I'm
gonna do that you know I just I you know
there was something that I just felt
that I could go after and there was
nothing that was gonna stop it and for
the first several years I was writing I
was deep in my acting career and writing
was more therapeutic to get my mind off
of the very painful trials and
tribulations of an acting career because
it's very difficult and you get rejected
a lot and all the cliches are absolutely
true and then but I was serious about it
but it was you know I think it just took
a while I'm realizing that beating
yourself up and I have no talent or this
is terrible or I'll work with
writer and they'll say oh that was shit
I said don't don't worry about it
don't worry about if it's good or bad
just let's just take a look at it and
see what what could be improved there's
no reason to be so caustic and hostile
about the material it's just words on
its screen you can change them it's just
changing so that's very much something
that guides me and in my work when I was
it's not that I'm not serious now but I
was so serious when I first started
which is a good thing but there were
certain things that I passed on because
in my young mind it wasn't serious
enough and it was it was a huge mistake
because there was a great experience
there to be had it isn't isn't always
about the quintessential part or
anything like that
so in that way I wish that I had taken
it just slightly less seriously I don't
think I'm the fastest learner but I
always say that if I get something I
have a chance to to do it well that's
that was my football career and
switching positions and the things that
I went through I didn't pick things up
very quickly but I was able to get it
eventually and then succeed at it and so
I've understood patience for a long time
because I've just I've known that about
myself so when I finished playing I
didn't you know I didn't put a time
limit like this has to happen in a year
or this has to happen in three years I
just said I'm just gonna be patient and
and train and learn and see what can
come from it and so I was just blessed
to have an opportunity come a couple of
years later where I could put some of
the training to work it's demoralizing
it's demoralizing it's hard to keep up
your enthusiasm and your
you oughtta veve about what you're doing
when you're only getting into the rooms
maybe once every one or two or three
months and I don't know if there's a way
around that other than to not let that
define who you are as a person I mean if
you're not auditioning and you and your
reaction to that is to just stay at home
and turn on old TV shows and you know
cry about not auditioning even I don't
think that really serves to help the
situation at all and and I used to do
that of course everybody you you're an
actor you want to be acting you want to
be given the opportunity to act and if
you're not getting those things it's
depressing and discouraging instead
though I mean and I still go through
those periods where there are you know
feast and famine times and when things
aren't as as fast as they have been in
the past you know I just I go out and do
something and I enjoy I find some other
thing to occupy my mind one of the best
things to do is to go help somebody else
because when I'm thinking about somebody
else and helping them what am I not
thinking about myself and my own
problems so I really strongly recommend
that in addition to you know whatever
interests outside of acting that you
have throw in some sort of volunteer
work III I can't tell you how much
that's benefited me and and gotten my
gotten me out of my own head sometimes
which is the worst place to be sometimes
just the worst
and those times will pass they always
have they always will of course you
always think with every job that it's
the last job you'll ever have you'll
never work again and the truth is I've
been doing this a long time and I have
been provided for by the universe
through all of it
and there's no reason to think that that
won't continue to happen for as long as
it's supposed to happen so I'm content
with that and if things are a little
slow
I'll just go off and do something else
that I enjoy like I said it's there's
all this time that time in-between which
is tough was it michael caine said you
know they pay me to wait acting i do for
free right so there you go it's a lot of
waiting around
so you just just got to stay at it and
work out and stay healthy and focus on
your craft and go for it when you get a
shot you know people always say how
difficult psychologically it is for
actors during the times that they're not
working and i don't think until you've
been an act or an experience that you
really understand the depths of how
difficult those times can be i think you
have to go through that so that you
start strategizing how to not
emotionally go through that the next
time that you have a downtime you know
how to be happy during those periods
when you know you're not the guy being
called for the the part in the film or
on a TV series and i I think that it's
you know the steel is tempered in the
fire sort of deal if you can if you can
make it through those tough times and
come out intact and maybe even a little
bit better it makes you that much more
interesting a person and therefore
hopefully an actor it's all in your
inner attitude you know you say you
don't want to do it well that's that's
being kind of simplistic about life
because you can always find some good in
any experience even a bad experience
something you think is bad could be a
good experience you don't even know that
until years later perhaps a weeks later
or days later you know sometimes the bad
things in life where you're being tried
is the things that make you grow so I
mean I look at it that way
so say five do a couple of movies I
always try to find some good in each of
those roles even if perhaps if I were
sitting on a pile of money I didn't have
to take that job maybe I would have
waited around for something better but
you know what do you think is better
mmm a lot of actors can sit around and
wait for a long time and nothing happens
but a lot of times you can do something
and and out of that energy comes
something that you can't even imagine
you know that's just how life is so so I
just I just take any role I just try to
make the best of it and try to enjoy it
that's how I look at it and this wasn't
one of those pictures just was one stuff
something I wanted to do but I do stuff
you know that sometimes I'm not a
hundred percent sure about but you know
what most of the time afterwards I'm
glad I did it
I always think that because something
good always happened you know there's no
real red flags beyond some the quality
though the perceived quality I perceived
I'd like to have you know be it
religiously inclined or however you say
that I don't know that that would stop
me from doing something if I thought it
read well enough and if it was decent
you know but yeah I'm pretty easy in
that sense you know being a working
actor in Los Angeles I got to pay my
rent so honestly if it comes through and
it's not the worst thing I've ever seen
I'll probably entertain the idea of
doing it because you always meet
interesting people uncertainly always
learn something even if the character
you're playing is is empty and shallow
and and you can't identify with it at
all you'll have an experience on set
that'll be worthwhile or just will be
working with someone new you'll make a
friend so there's so many facets to it I
feel like I'm not really out of position
to be super picky with stuff you know
I'm not being offered things left and
right and crazy huge productions I still
go to auditions every every time I need
to book something so you know I take
what comes
what comes around and if it's good then
great and if it's not then yeah
something something will happen anyway
every every jobs a new operator
you know you have to be willing I mean
you can't get so into like well I've got
to keep up you got to be willing to take
a shot on something and fall on your
face too but every single thing is a new
experience it's a chance to learn about
something else a chance to work with
some new great people so I don't know
the older I get I don't I don't the less
competitive I feel about it you know
it's just I feel like I'm lucky to be
here and it's it's more of a
collaborative thing you know it's life
that matters not only what you do on
film on television it pushes your
personal growth ultimately that's why we
were all here and you can still have
great do great work but you know it
wasn't such a great life maybe for you
or for your children or for your family
your friends so you have to kind of stay
close to yourself and your personal
growth while you're trying to get this
other stuff done in the business and
that's kind of that balance is quite
hard to hit and that's I think work you
know I I work on that every day and I
think a lot of you know think that's one
of my strengths perhaps that I've stayed
kind of close to to Who I am who I was
before I get in here in this crazy town
you know they think that is what people
have to remember because that's the big
thing that will derail you failure or
success can screw you up you know it's
the middle way like Buddha says the
middle way that's where you should be
most of the time and that's that's the
healthiest way of existing I think
because the big stuff is great but it
always goes away and it can lead to a
lot of negatives and the really lows too
or tough as well so you need to
understand the middle ground I had a
moment where I just had a series of
adults and children all asked me if I
was an actor for vows I reminded them of
this actor or this character all within
like seems like a six six to eight week
span I'd have people with me and be
happening it was happening like just so
frequently it was just really like all
right maybe I should listen to the
voices so these people that I don't know
becoming either and I asked my
grandfather my mom wasn't into it it's
just no way now you're not gonna make it
she actually laughed at me which sucks
as a kid you turn to your parents as
mentors and teachers and missing out but
that's a whole nother story grandpa said
yes so I'm grateful for that
when he said you can do it that's all I
needed to hear it from somebody that I
cared about that I knew cared about me
telling me something like that is
different because of the type of movies
like x-men or Jurassic world this kind
of type of movie I can I can't do in
France like to have a character a kind
of superhero I can't do that in France
that's that's the type of that's the
type of genre I can't do in France and
also the directors I work with in u.s.
they're not they're not working in
France so that's that's the difference
and for me as an actor I learned a lot
with Eric and Olivia that they're there
the first year tour making we acting so
I have my way to connect to a boil in a
project it's the director so so I love
meeting directors so that the directors
I met here was what's good was a good
experience for me make me grow as an
actor so um I hope it will be continued
I suppose if I were to advise my younger
self I would've said don't start so
early
really yeah even though I got really
lucky like they're the only reason that
I'm still in the industry's gonna came
over the right time when I did the right
audition and I and I booked it and Rob
Ryan I was very kind to cast me I would
say become a better person or that of
human you know a more evolved version of
yourself before you come and start doing
interviews and talking to people and and
and I suppose in making yourself known I
would have liked to started now because
I'm now I'm quite comfortable with who I
am and I think part of who I am is born
of this industry now having been here
for six years and done so much traveling
while I've been here
it might not be Who I am now
should I have not come early but as I am
now I'd say to myself don't come early
go finish school you know good I wanted
to be I wanted to be either a physicist
or a cytologist I got me a marine
biologist and someone who studies whales
I would have loved to have done that
even if I could just swim with a whale I
would have been content and then come
and been an actor in America I don't
know yeah I feel like I feel like I was
still too much a kid I didn't really
know who I was or what I was doing and I
wish I'd never spoken to anyone out here
while I was that young well of course I
I couldn't have gotten to the business
if I didn't know any anybody or two and
just having this this interest in in
acting and if and if you don't want to
act you don't you don't necessarily have
to and but it's something that you do if
you truly want to do it so um you know
if if if you're interested by acting and
if you're interested in in being
somebody else then you should definitely
pursue and you also want to direct one
day um I would like to direct one day um
yeah that's why I'm I'm so happy that I
was able to work with Bob and everybody
else the two of you direct each other at
any point I wouldn't dream of it
wouldn't dream of it
it's the writing first and foremost for
me it can be any genre you know we're
actors we both like to do things all
over the place you know creatively but
it has to be the writing has to be good
and and for me it doesn't matter if
you're a first-time writer director and
actors you know actors there are a lot
of great actors there that we know
people's names and there's a lot of
actors out there that we don't know so
I'm open creatively it just comes down
to the writing in the material there's a
thing that happens where you look at the
page number you're on the first page
number you're on and if you're on page
eight you're already looking at the page
number that's a bad sign yeah if you
look down and you're on page 67 or
something and you're open you're still
awake yeah and you're good the scripts a
good read yeah for me I always kind of
start with character obviously because
that's like the first place that I'm
gonna be entering into it and is it a
guy that I'm interested in playing and
someone who I haven't played before and
and some shoes that I want to walk in
for for the time that I'm there and then
I would say you know you got to look at
the director and start to think about
whether or not this this thing that's on
the page is is is gonna become you know
close to what's here in in in his in his
mind I would say that comedians you it's
really necessary to know yourself that
that's part of the journey is and that's
part of the conversation you have with
the audience and how they respond to
things particularly autobiographical
things so you become very aware of who
you are and how you come across but I
don't know I think of acting and
stand-up is very different disciplines
but I also I love acting because it's in
some ways it's the opposite of stand-up
where a stand-up a writer director
producer and
every beatin moment of the show is
controlled and influenced by me I love
the opportunity to be this spoken this
larger just even a moment in a scene
serving a narrative of a story is is
really exciting and also it's fun too to
kind of hide in a different character
and have a different a different point
of view I mean I think in my stand-up I
kind of engaged different points of
views but in acting it's really fun to
kind of climb behind a different point
of view and see how they would adjust of
course it's still you but you know like
playing Paul Markham you know he's a
lawyer so that's I think that that
influenced how he viewed everything it
was also someone who really liked Ted so
I think those elements really had an
influence whereas in stand-up there's a
greater likelihood of taking the
irreverent point of view it's definitely
fun to put yourself in other people's
shoes you know just to kind of be a
little apathetic to like what you would
do or what another person would do how
another person would act I do live life
and work separately so that's why I kind
of don't feel like I'm living someone
else's life but I really do live my life
to the fullest and then I have an
amazing job that gets me to like you
know tap into other people's lives I'd
like to be challenged I like to can't be
challenged and do things that I haven't
done before so that's when I get to
learn a new skill set when I get to jump
into another culture another life style
you know there's only a handful of roles
that I really won't play like pedophiles
I just can't I can't I can't the
research on that is taxing on the soul I
don't I don't
I'm very anti that yeah
characters are realizations from
people's imaginations so naturally some
were going to fit with your imagination
and some are
and some are based off of real people in
our accurate depictions and some are so
you have to use discernment and figure
out what speaks to you what's real to
you and everything is not gonna be I
think when you first start acting you're
gonna take anything that comes at you
can juggle work that's understandable
that's what I did that's what I think
most actors did when they first started
out because you need to work it is a job
but at the same time once you start to
develop your craft and you can sort of
weed out what speaks to you and what's
important because it's also important to
do things that correlate with your
frequency that go with how you're
attempting to move because if it doesn't
you're portraying something that isn't
genuine and then your performance is
people are going to see it and be like
this something isn't genuine about that
so just make sure it connects to you
this is why it's important I think to
expand your horizons and awareness so I
way more things have the ability to sort
of click with you because the the broad
the more broaden your horizon is the
more chance of yeah I know what that is
rather than living in a sort of vacuum
and then something coming into your
awareness you - that's too foreign I
don't know what that is you know and
never judge the characters I it's an
interesting thing when you're when
you're playing a character or when I'm
when I'm playing a character because I'm
basically going through a process where
I'm not looking to be reductive at all
or to judge the person I could I could
from a different point of view talk
about Bobby and talk about some of the
things he said and and say they were
awful and destructive and I I I do
believe that but in terms of kind of
where my sympathy lies I have to go dig
into this without judgment and just try
to understand right I look at behavior
and I'm really just trying to understand
behavior not judge the behavior so I I
find Bobby Fischer fascinating and I
have might kind of I guess assessments
as as I apply them
to how I'm portraying him one of my
great acting teachers when I was a very
young actor I asked a similar question
he said I'm gonna make it real simple
for you he said it's like falling into
darkness backward imagine just falling
into darkness backward no control of
your landing you're gonna be caught or
not just fall embraceable supposes are
rocked back there or suppose there's a I
don't know no pillows and just hard
floor the writer is saying to you I want
you to fall into darkness backward I've
given you all the description the
director and I of who the character is
we've had rehearsals and discussions
about who this Peyman being is I do not
want you to describe them to me I want
you to become them by falling into
darkness backward can you do that I mean
that's kind of like a weird thing it's
something that you try not to be
conscious of you know I tried to be
conscious too much of my body movements
you know it's kind of maybe something
that just you hope just happens
naturally and
you know if you're I guess if you're
focused on if you're focused on the the
important task at hand right it was
right if you're focused on the result
that's the bad thing if you focus at the
real task at hand and that's that's the
good thing in so and if if you believe
if you're trying your hardest to believe
in this fake scenario which is what it
is then hopefully if you trick your mind
well enough maybe hopefully that comes
across yeah I also think that certainly
we convey emotion through our eyes in
every way including crying but I think
maybe more important even is I think we
convey intelligence through our eyes do
you know what I mean when I when I watch
someone understand something I see it a
little bit in their body language but I
mostly see it in their eyes or when I
see someone worried about something or
trying to figure something out like it's
the eyes are the where you see the most
reaction do you know so III one of the
most important things I think on film
that's very different from onstage is as
human beings were thinking all the time
or calculating and were you know
maneuvering and planning and I think
that we see that somewhat in our body
language but mostly in in our eyes we
see we see the other person think and so
when you see an actor really thinking
on-screen you believe they're a real
person watching stuff from you I mean I
been acting for four and a half years
now I'm watching so my first stuff I
remember thinking at the time because
especially the movies you shoot it and
then you don't get to see it until like
a year more later you know and you've
grown and changed so much in that time
so watching it you're like sometimes I
think oh why did I why did I convey that
emotion or why did I make that face and
you're looking at it but you're
nitpicking things and at the time I
believe I did the best I could you know
and it's just I think it just slight
unconscious things of just learning to
trying you know put all the motions
there and have stuff beyond the eyes and
really know that there's a process going
on yeah I find that like most of the
learning happens in the process of
making the film and that I can't I
usually watch a film or anything that
I've made like maybe one time and then
sort of put it away I think the the
general thing as an actor as a young
actor is like you want to lean into
those emotions the big emotions in a
project and the arc of a character and I
think that's something I've learned over
the years has made me to avoid leaning
into those emotions too much I don't
need anything I can cook I can cry I can
laugh I can get angry I am like a sieve
it just goes in and out of me and it's
all fun
I like feelings I like to have a lot of
feelings I love to cry I love to get
angry I love to be scared I love to do
all the feelings joy I'm trying to think
of this any feeling that I don't like
playing the hardest feeling to play is
no feeling to be repressed to be doubt
to be boring is the hardest thing to
play because there's a lot of feeling
that goes into no feeling there's a lot
of feeling that goes into repression a
lot of feelings well you have all the
feelings but you don't show them you
don't express them they're all there and
you rise above them or you don't show
them actually it's a very interesting
thing to play it was quite you know a
dry piece of photo she's interviewing
someone so this subject takes up most of
the air and it's about a zoning board
petition in Sarasota it's not the most
thrilling better material but it was you
know in the in the 70s often they'd
shoot things in one
static wide shot so I was able to watch
her all the way through and watch her
responses and her body language and her
and you know you can it sounds like a
short amount of stuff to to go on but
actually you can into it an awful lot
about someone from the first meeting as
we
and often those intuitions are quite
powerful so if so that the building of
the character felt like an exercise in
letting that intuition work on this bit
of footage and building it from that
everything get my hands on one of the
best things I've got my hands on was
some old sailing footage of Ted and Joe
certain the way rowers are the boats you
know but they sailed on Chappaquiddick
you know just seeing them that day on
the phone Ted on the phone in the gear
young dudes looking you know Ray Bans
Joe was smoking a cigarette bless sail
on the boat you know just you're looking
for something that captures you know
them when they they got the look of a
boat the public one the unguarded ones
the little moments the mannerisms you
know the funeral there's so much on
these guys the whole family you know I
watched a lot of and read a lot of the
other brothers not just tellin it over
terror what for the others I went for
the family you know went for what you
know as pictures of Joe you know how to
behave around your father you know
there's so much this and the particular
speeches some of the some of the most
some of the some of the greatest
speeches ever said and written
particularly by Bobby I just try to read
it once a day from the first of the last
page on and there's no really there's no
real strategy or I don't have a there's
just more by reading it once a day I
feel like I things happen and I come up
with thoughts and ideas and and I'll
discover something even if it's the 55th
time I read the script is something else
I'll discover something or come up with
in an idea for the character or idea for
a specific scene or it could be
something more general on and then a lot
of those ideas are terrible and but by
doing that at least like its thought
something starts a kind of a an internal
creative process where and then it's
more about filter out those 99% of bad
ideas and then holding on to those ones
that you think are actually good for the
foundation of the character in a way so
yeah it's just the way I prepare it is I
work all the time on
on backstory all the time so I know what
it is I'm talking about because a line
can mean many different things and I
need to know specifically what I mean by
what I say all my characters no matter
how small the part is I'm just trying to
get in the headspace of that character's
point of view and so I'm constantly
trying to and I basically when I write I
act out the parts in my head as I'm
writing them and I used to think I was
crazy
and then I read an interview with Aaron
Sorkin where he said he played all the
parts as he read as he wrote them in his
head and I thought oh I do do you know
it was with his relief that okay with a
great screenwriter of our times is what
he does so and that had been my process
so that's what I'm constantly just
trying to get into the voice and the
headspace of the characters as I write
them when I take on a role I'm going to
do whatever research I possibly can you
know in terms of fort bliss it was
really important to me I mean these are
these are real people that we're
portraying and if you're not going to do
it the right way then I'm I'm not going
to do it you know and I don't think
anybody else should do it unless they're
gonna do whatever whether they're
playing um a truck driver a doctor you
know soldier whatever it is so that's
that's a very high standard for myself
and in doing that and having that
approach gives me confidence so that's
um first and foremost it's just it's
just doing the research and doing the
work I did quite a bit I watched and
listened to anything I could get my
hands on and kept doing that you know
for a long time
firstly to learn about him in the
beginning as we were setting out to
figure out what the movie was I you know
read a bunch and watched as much as I
could find and then and then later as we
had we were going towards making the
movie then I would just I would just
listen to him constantly or you know
watch interviews every day I went to a
local trainer here one of the greatest
trainers in the world Freddie Roach and
I went through Manny Pacquiao and versus
Bradley their training camp and Freddie
taught me everything he knows about
about being a trainer whispering in the
ear doing the mitts you know giving him
water the chess game that you play so I
got a pretty good education and then I
found unfortunately Kevin Rooney is in
the hospital with dementia and so I
wasn't able to work with him but I
worked with his son and I learned as
much as I could about him and and put it
on screen when I go in for the audition
I usually haven't read the script just
because I don't know it's probably like
an ego thing I'm always like Carly knows
they probably won't cost me anyway so
why should I read their script but
honestly it's just because I'm kind of
lazy but these days I've gotten better
at it I will read the script before I go
in but certainly when I'm when I'm
casting something I'll read it through a
couple times beforehand but I like to I
also like to discuss it with the other
actors a little bit and see what their
take of it is a bit yeah I don't know I
don't read it too many times because I
don't want it to be stale for me you
know it's like if ever you I don't know
if you've ever tried to write anything
I've always been trying to write things
my whole life yeah but I usually leave
it too long and so I've read through the
thing so many times and I've read it so
many times that I lose interesting at
myself so for for a script I you know
five times maybe five or six times but
until wrap any more than that and I
think I'll get bored of it we still had
a couple days before we started shooting
and you know during the wardrobe
fittings and all that you're still
discussing the characters even
discussing things and I mean I spent
time looking at the script beforehand
but you could only do so much prep work
you know especially on such an improv
based movie like I know we knew the
general motion so it was about 20
minutes before each scene where Hannah
would come
okay so this is kind of what we need to
information we need to get across in the
scene and here's like a line or two in
case you can't think of anything and
then she kind of just let us loose yeah
I think yeah it's totally project
dependent like certain characters demand
a certain type of preparation if you're
going to change your physicality or your
voice or something like that and other
and sometimes you have a lot of time
right and sometimes you just don't
sometimes you only have a week or
something so it just depends because
I've had both experiences I I really I
mean most of the projects that I've
worked on are scripted and one if the
script is well written and well and
ready then it doesn't need you to be
improvising and most of the directors
that I worked with whether it's Wolfgang
Petersen or or Sydney Pollack they don't
want you improvising the script is is
crafted in a certain kind of way and
that's the way they want it but this is
a different situation
so sometimes it's marvelous and
sometimes it seems really chaotic so I
have both feelings about it
everybody's got their particular route
but the thing I think is important to be
an actor is always keep an open mind
always be willing to learn and don't
reach a point where you feel like I've
learned enough and now I don't need to
know anything else because as you know
your talent will take you so far but you
need to be constantly trying to develop
skills and learning how to access these
characters and analyze these stories and
tell them in the most authentic light
and why your talent will take you a long
way and won't take you to the heights
that you want to go because there's a
cap a moment where you're like well this
is this is just about talent so you need
to constantly stretch yourself travel
meet new people engage in new
experiences fearlessly and sort of
download that information into sort of
creating what you want to create every
role is different so what may work for
one role may not work for another and
vice versa sometimes your talent will be
great for a certain role and then for
another role you have to reach outside
the sort of boundaries of your
natural talent in order to tap into it
those are things that I find the most
rewarding and the most difficult and
they caused me to have to get studious
and learn all these things you know and
get into these different lifestyles and
understanding so always keep an open
mind and I think you can explore and do
whatever you need to do and realize
remember this game is not a competition
it seems like a competition but it's not
the only person you're a competition
with is yourself
and if you think you can't do a certain
thing you can't if you think you can you
can't you just gotta push yourself as
true as we think we're being to
ourselves we can always be a little
truer you know seeking a depth of
authenticity if you will you don't like
like I just I've just on this crazy
journey lately through my work and the
demands of trying to do better work it's
pushed me to to lose sleep and study
harder and faster and just go longer and
it's um it's just interesting because if
you pay attention to the signs in those
moments and do what's right you know
what speaks to your integrity
I can always rest well with whatever
happens you know I'm not feeling bad I'm
feeling good about the decisions I make
not a good feeling
do what you love and do what inspires
you when you see it that makes you feel
something or make makes you want to do
that thing but also listen to people's
criticism like I feel like that one
mistake I feel like I see comedians make
because comedians tend to be it myself
included it's dubbing people but is when
comedians or any other artists are just
kind of like no it's my way and and I
just and they don't want to take
criticism you have to take criticism
from people you trust
you know IRA and I I feel like thrive on
that in terms of he's really critical
and it had lately though it helped
surround ourselves with people who
critique our work and and we change our
work and it's a constant process of
trying to make the work better there are
some actors mention their names but
they're
they are so involved in legitimacy of
what they do they're there before the
crew and me they just sit on this set
and sit in this seat they know they're
gonna be in sometimes or if they're if
it's supposed to be their bedroom
they'll go in the bedroom and touch the
props and do what is never become
familiar with the pictures on the wall
and what's in the closet what kind of
bed sheets are they what color is the
bedding house off to the pillows and why
those pills that softer why are they
harder or is the blind closed or is it
open and there's a curtains on the wall
and why was that color chosen for this
sheet and ah okay and they're
comfortable because it's their bedroom
for the last 15 years so sometimes they
come to this set two days before and
they just sit there and they become
organically ingrained some of the great
actors have their own ways of becoming
the truth of what they're supposed to be
and I get there and they're there hey
Bill how you doing man you know I hear
me you know what I'm doing working I see
yeah thank you because I respect that
they don't just wait for you to tell
them what to do they have their only
because I'm an actor too as you start
surrendering to a character that the
author is written it's it's gonna sound
crazy but the character tries to live
through you if you accept him or her I
was playing a character once in a movie
forgot which one he was and week before
us pulls a film I started doing this
Neven of my life my girl for the times
what are you doing I said wait she said
she's going I said no I'm not she says
okay what - later I'm going
that was the character coming through me
and so I put that in part of the film
because I knew something that it's being
expressed to one person and it's trust
trusting your instincts yourself and
your talent I was on the on an airplane
once with Al Pacino I did a film called
sea of love with him and we were flying
to Toronto to rehearse and he was
talking about John Gielgud in a film and
he said he's gotten free and it I didn't
know what that meant but I knew Pacino
knew what it meant and moreover the way
he said it there was a sense of
reverence about the notion that an actor
had gotten free that John Gilbert's been
doing this for a long time and so it out
Pacino so the the the thing was he was
saying about his performance he's gotten
free well I saw that Oh McConaughey he
was free any impulse any thought any
movement any moment it was it was like
he was free to do whatever came to him
and that instant whatever he was playing
off of whatever preparation he had he
was utterly free with it and I thought
we do something special here we're in
something really special here you know
to find your way into somebody else's
mind is is a process and the more you
learn about how they lived who they were
how they express themselves in a number
of different situations can in trying to
put yourself into their shoes can often
lead you to what they were thinking
under those circumstances and that I
find to be captivating if you can
actually get into it you know
it's a fragile business I find it often
it's like splitting atoms in some ways
because we all have our own things going
on in our heads and to try to submerge
yourself into something else as a is a
wonderful challenge not often is one
successful in actually producing a
complete performance or a complete
character but it's it's really fun to
try I pride myself in being least trying
to be a professional right and I know
you do the same yes and you're
incredible at it but it's also it's a
it's good to have a combination of being
professional but also having a lot of
fun on set and not taking it too
seriously where you can't enjoy yourself
when you're not actually rolling and so
just creating a beautiful environment
for the cast and crew and a safe place
to kind of experiment and test yourself
and that that is going back to Aaron
said you know making sure that when we
come off stay at stage set that you are
supported and and you have a good bunch
of people around you that you you know
honor you and you want to honor them
return so yeah it was very much that on
this project but I do think you're
always looking for something to learn
and take with you it's great when you
don't have to be conscious of blocking
that was great so in Hannah's maybe we
didn't have to be aware of it too much
I mean Hannah would be like okay cameras
probably be in this general area but she
still let us move and they can
with us exactly it's all about following
what we were doing with this phone which
is great I like to really think about
that stuff when we're rehearsing because
that's when you sort of with this film
is less locked-in but when you do the
rehearsal which is right before you
shoot it that's when you start to lock
yourself into things so I really think
about it a lot then and then I try to
totally forget about it yeah I mean
sometimes it's hard I remember there was
a I was shooting season one of American
Horror Story and on the pilot there was
this one there's this one moment where I
walk in and I'm supposed to walk a
certain way or not slam my feet I don't
remember and I right before they would
say action I would think okay pick up
your feet don't don't make that don't
make that sound that's bothering the the
sound Department and every time five
times the row I completely forgot as
soon as they said actually it's hard to
think about the real life at the same
time when you're like okay and in the
character I'm playing this person now
and literally I even though I just
reminded myself like 10 seconds before
they said action I couldn't remember to
pick up my feet a certain way yeah give
me hard sometimes but with actors it's
uh you don't get together for fun and
read lines you know you don't get to get
together for fun hey what are you doing
this weekend you know let's read a play
together but musicians it's hey dude you
know we're gonna be down it you know
whatever rehearsal hall down here in the
valley and and we're gonna jam and so so
this I'm not saying that musicians
aren't competitive they are but it's
more about the creation of the content
of the song it's about the song so
everybody loves to get together to make
music acting is bit competitive I know
that the most successful actors that
I've worked with and I won't have to
name any names that they can be very
friendly and cooperative and then once
they put the clapper and say action they
would step on your throat to to beat you
in a scene that that and it was it was
so funny to me because the education
that I received when I was studying to
be an actor was that you you play with
one another that your scene partners
that if I'm a good tennis player and the
person that I'm playing again is not
very good what I have to do is try to
improve their game because I'm not going
to be able to have a good game and show
you how good a player I am if the other
player can't hit the ball back to me so
if I'm just smashing the ball and making
the person run all over the place
the that it's just it's it's not gonna
work that you want to try to make the
scene as best as possible acting I feel
like you gotta use whatever stimuli
whatever stimuli you can grab onto to
sort of like get you into a scene i
working on sons of anarchy and i had
known a couple of the guys on the set
and i did a guest start and then halfway
through the day i walked over to where
they were all kind of hanging out and i
won't mention which one of the guys but
he goes get out of here this isn't your
scene and we were i about to do a scene
together and I was like hurt you know
and like a couple the other actors they
were like oh don't worry about it it's
okay you know it's don't don't don't
take it personally so I walked away and
I was like you know and then it got me
going you know and then I used it in the
scene and then but and you get there so
it works not something I would do to
another actor however you know however
it comes out sometimes you got to take
it there in order to go somewhere else
no I wouldn't say I'm attracted to
dangerous characters I'm I'm attracted
to characters that have conflict because
for me it's always more interesting than
a character that hasn't got conflict and
it's more real and so a character's
grappling with something he's always
much more interested played
more than one thing to play all the time
and this film certainly falls into that
bracket because he's a father estranged
from his son who's trying to make a go
of it and trying to do the right thing
and it's very difficult in his
circumstances and he's got some demons
he's dealing with but you know so it
certainly falls into the bracket of you
know a character in conflict it wasn't
from the standpoint that I have to play
a character that everyone admires you
know I love playing villainous roles but
no villain ever thinks of themselves as
evil they did the right thing in their
estimation but there's no getting around
he did something that terrifies any
parent you know that's like their worst
fear but again that wasn't so as
important in the largest scheme of
things I was just trying to understand a
person that would do that and I think
Jane Addams who plays my wife does a lot
in making you understand their
relationship and how controlling and
aggressive she is but she brings a lot
more to the table than those in the
script so we were really lucky to have
her as an actor there's a lot in
football as far as just the preparation
that really got me ready for acting you
know just the way that I knew I had to
be a student and I had to study and I
had to train and then at the moment
where we said though I had to throw all
of that away and just go off instinct
and that's acting you know so I just he
used a lot of the same tools that I did
in football and I spread it over to act
and do same things first of all as an
actor you always want to go for being
presence you don't want to act and the
moment you act I would say whenever I
act in the film you say cut always
because you can see it instantly if
that's his eye
so I would always go and try my goal for
all times is to be present but but but
especially with dubious films it's it's
difficult because he creates some
surroundings that are so realistic
that's why we used soldiers who have
served in Afghanistan and Iraq so we can
keep this nerve and this
realism that that creates a natural flow
of character and story so I know as a
trained actor what to do and what not to
because these guys have done it between
10 and 15 years so it's actually a gift
that's the reason why he in my case he's
acting when I'm acting but it's
different with other actors I love
seeing all these people now that you
know they're all surfers you know
Matthew McConaughey but I understand why
I do because you can only be in the
moment it's like rock climbing I used to
be a rock climber as well you can only
be in the moment when you're doing that
or you're going to get in you're just
going to wipe out in not such a good way
and one has to feel the emotion of the
nature of the beast that you're on and
so yeah I learned a lot a lot about
endurance and and keeping my eyes open
certainly I think a great actor is
someone who can feel as they listen
because a lot of the best moments I
think happen when you're not talking
your response to another person is
something that can feed them in a way
that just having your line when it's
your turn to speak doesn't you know you
can I can see it happened I've been on
both sides of the giving and the
receiving of that where you have your
moment and what I do just what my
response to you what my eyes say what my
body says is I can see the other person
going deeper into what it is that they
want to say because they're they know
that they are being heard and it is a
natural kind of symbiotic thing a
wonderful quote from either Julie Harris
of fantastic actress or Helen Hayes
another fantastic actress was this she
there was a seat she was doing a play on
Broadway and she had to do it night
after night after night for months and
months and months and there is a scene
in which she comes downstage and sits on
a park bench and has a moment and weeps
and someone came up to and they're
talking about the scene and what she's
thinking and all that and the person
says to her the interviewer says how can
you cry every night and she says how can
you not because and that was the end of
the quote was how can you not but
because she was in that moment she was
feeling that feeling she was hearing
those words or feeling that feeling and
how can you not respond to that if
you're really hearing so that's what I
think makes a wonderful actor is being
able to hear and feel whether you're
talking or not all of us are everything
and people say why can you say that I'm
a woman with a child I'm not a murderer
okay
suppose somebody just came up and made
sure a baby in a head with a hammer
what would you call your response to
that if you picked that hammer up no
one's saying you're a murderer and no
one's saying you're anything but you're
everything and if you're hired to do a
job the director doesn't hire you to act
like that person
the director hires you to become that
person and that's something I must be
able to understand about acting acting
is not how that word is annoying because
it means you're pretending acting is not
pretending
things becoming it's surrendering to the
spirit of whatever your that character
you're describing is so thing called
stage right that's when you're in the
middle you've given part of yourself up
to be the character but your ego and
your fear and paranoia is watching how
you give it up and tries to control the
shape of that giving up but real actors
like the ones that I adore the Kate
Winslet's and the Meryl Streep's and the
denzel's when he's really in it and the
Sam Jackson's and philip Seymour
Hoffman's and the Geoffrey rights and
when those people go there there's no
there's nobody there except that
character and that's admirable it takes
courage people to understand because
sometimes you're not control you're
you're you're on a ride if the trust and
the person you trust the director to say
that I ride right what do you think cuz
you don't stand outside and look at your
ride you ride and that's what real great
actors do main thing I say is I would
never ask an actor to do something I
couldn't do and I'm not the best actor
in the world I'm a decent actor but I'm
not the best the people who I get who I
asked to play these parts they are all
better than me at what they're doing at
the part that they're doing so I know if
I can do that make the transition I
asked them to make or play an emotion in
the scene I know they can do it because
I I can do it I would never ask him to
do something I couldn't do certainly you
know I've been on both sides of that
equation obviously I'm an actor as well
so I and
find that I find that the more the more
delicate a director tries to be the more
frustrating it is for for everyone
involved I find the more direct you can
be and the less you can say the better
the better you are the bed the better it
is for everybody
interesting so you're not sort of
tiptoeing around trying to know just
some direct and concise you know I I
find me as a director and me and maybe
it's because I you know I'm so you know
I I understand the secret language of
actors because I'm one as well but I can
go up and just say one word to an actor
and and you know go Oh got it okay good
and and that's it like the less you can
say the better god learn learn an
American accent just do it because
there's so many Australians that I know
come over and I'll talk to them and I'll
show you oh if you got your American
accent down and they'll say oh no no but
I'm you know I'll get to that eventually
and I feel like almost before you should
even arrange any papers or before you
should even book a flight or just
consider well would you be a twinkle in
your eye the idea of living here moving
here you should have an American accent
down I feel like but yeah it's it was
fairly natural I don't deserve any
credit for it if it is if it is
convincing I've been here for six years
I ought to have it down by now but I
think I had pretty much down when I
first moved here because in Australia
and I've made the joke before but I
honestly think it's because I grew up
like slightly racist you know and it's
slightly racist Australian environment
you know cuz we make fun of everyone
it's you know and so I was growing up
doing Indian Scottish Irish American
accents I'm pretty sure my first word in
an American accent was cheeseburger if
that gives you any idea of what I'm
getting at so yeah I think it was always
there and then I just I had to
professionalize it if you catch my drift
difficult for me it was a really tough
camera shot too because there's a really
lot of long takes in that one and a lot
of movement so that was like another
challenge but so that was a really
challenging one and therefore one of the
most fun to shoot yeah it's hard when
it's not only physically
exhausting you know like it's a bit we
had to move around a lot we're also
emotionally exhausting you put those two
together over shooting till like 3:00
a.m. and you didn't realize where the
time goes and you're just so tired yeah
we were after that scene we were so like
drain yeah but then you also have a moat
you just saw so proud you have a moment
of accomplishment okay I feel like we
got it yeah
I had a dream of you know I wanted to
even when I did not watch I'd already
been accepted to a theater school in
England so I was always just finished
four years of training and demo'd then I
was going to do this movie and then go
to Bristol Old Vic you know where Daniel
day-lewis had gone it was very exciting
I went there for two weeks and then I
ran away but I always wanted you to act
and I wanted to travel the world if I
could and so that was the plan then I
moved to London and then slowly but
surely I started getting work absolutely
not there was no way that I wasn't going
to take it no no I I came out here and
shortly thereafter I got what at the
time was probably my biggest break which
was playing the heavy in Karate Kid 3
and I got it from an open-call standing
in line with 1,500 other people and John
avildsen who had won the Academy Award
for rocky picked me out of a line and I
wound up being cast and that really you
know that really changed the trajectory
of my career I was doing my parents
dreams I was I did finance work
yeah the banking world and what happened
I blew it I'll tell you what happened I
got laid off run around 9/11 and I
already have used up all my vacation
days I knew that I was just a horrible
investment banker I just I hated it when
I knew it wasn't gonna last I don't know
it just wasn't I you know I knew at that
point my life that I had to at least try
something that I cared about and that
began the journey of me kind of like
spending a year going and doing a lot of
crazy stuff and then eventually after a
while I was in LA I was bartending I was
thinking I'll go to law school and I got
asked to do an audition and next thing
you know I was a full-time actor it was
crazy I feel like like you do actually
kind of have to ignore your parents and
your family when they discourage you
from doing what you want to do I think
your parents did they actually want you
to do something besides comedy was there
a specific thing that my dad would just
always say like you know there's a in a
very supportive way you know this might
parlay nicely into advertised
this whole comedy thing like no no this
is it this is the plan like this is
going well when you're like when I was
making like I don't know 500 bucks a
week driving my mom station wagon around
the country opening for bigger comedians
look I was like success like in my mind
I was like that's I don't know how to
dream what does that average out to a
year's that that's like 25 now when in
success I was a year I was like fine
great like if I can pay my rent I'll do
this for the rest of my life
I had this experience when my parents of
the UH they said I've said this before
and it makes them upset but it's true
they're the only Jews in America who
don't like public broadcasting and they
completely disapproved of me working in
public radio in my 20s and we're
constantly trying to get me to go to
medical school which they only stopped
like after I was in my mid-thirties I
feel like my parents wanted me to go to
something like medical school but not a
medical school because then I could have
the potential to hurt people
look I botch a surgery or you know
because I'm so clumsy like they kind of
knew like you should go to medical
school
maybe not medical school yeah something
like medical school something stable and
academic but maybe not something we're
watching people's innards yeah I just
got out of high school trying to figure
out what I want to do and why kind of
knew what I wanted to do I knew I wanted
to act in some capacity so I started
really just googling acting schools
acting stuff anything that encompassed
acting trying to find a sort of channel
in and so I just googled everything and
pages and pages of things popped up and
I just filled everything out and then
eventually you know people started
answering and a lot of those were scams
and things that I would ultimately end
up wasting my time and so I ended up
going back and forth from LA to
Victorville scrambling up changing one
time it was a school for modeling and
career center modeling careers and so
they I just get up on the runway taught
us to walk the runway and taught us all
the names of the brands and finding you
know GE proud of all these different
things that would be of no use to me
really but at the time I realized every
other week they had agents come in for
the people that wanted to aspire to get
into
so I wanted to get in front of these
agents and when one of those agents came
through I said I want to go in this is
audition day was like every Thursday or
something like that
and they said what do you have anything
prepared I said yes
I didn't win it anyway and I just did
the first thing that came to my mind
which is basically just to jump up up up
woman chair do some random stuff and the
guy saw something in me that he liked
and he signed me to his commercial
agency from there I began to do
auditions and fail and learn what it
meant to be rejected but be in the room
and sort of build my comfortability over
time so it would prove to be a very
important chapter although at the time I
just thought it was like I was wasting
my time but I proved to be very
important once I got out there and we
started auditioning I felt comfortable
because I had been rejected and I've
been through all of it already so
there's nothing left to fear so yeah
that was what came of the internet do
you feel like you're living your calling
yeah I do I definitely do you know back
when I was younger I thought my calling
was to be a midwife and deliver babies
which has been a passion of mine since I
was as long as I can remember and that's
what I really thought I was gonna do
until I literally just got a job in
acting I never went to school or did
anything and once I started doing this I
was like whoa like this I can't imagine
myself doing anything else so now I'm
just gonna have my own babies and just
continue to be an actress
did you receive signs along the way I
mean I know that's like you know what no
I I do believe in signs and you know
looking back I do kind of believe that I
was put in certain situations and times
where a lot of people aren't like I was
hanging out with people in the industry
huge names when I was like 17 years old
you know I was put in places and and
things have happened in my life that
allowed me to be where I'm at right now
and I find all those to be signs I
definitely that's the only reason why
I'm here is because I follow up those
signs and when opportunity knocks I
opened every single one of those doors
and then an interesting sort of audition
story that I tell a lot
again this is something I learned when
the Fast and the Furious audition came
my way again where I was at in my time
at that time in my life I didn't realize
what I had I was off in my own sort of
thinking about what I thought about the
business I got the audition and it was
called red line actually at the time and
I I remember passing on the audition and
why cuz I just didn't wanna I had in my
mind I wanted to do something completely
different with my life at the time again
maybe 23 years old you know so I got the
audition
I passed got the audition twice I passed
right my agent at the time calls me up
and says what are you doing like you
really want to pass on this and I said
yeah I mean I was just being a little
punk it's just like fine hung up the
phone on me I'm like yeah right my mom
making decision decisions another agent
from the same agency called me up and he
said you know come on go in and I'm like
okay I'll go in I was being a brat I was
being a brat and I way not auditioning
and I met the director Rob Cohen he's
very friendly and so nice and the
casting director who I love and so I
auditioned and and they liked what I did
and then they called me back or they
want me to come back and read with a
couple of the other actors and so I'm
like and then you start to like sort of
play it in your mind like oh oh you like
me okay you know all right yeah yeah
I'll go back yeah sure so I go in and I
read with where they was Matt Schulze at
the time and I'm Johnny strong I believe
and they were trying to fit like the
guys that you know cuz they already had
you know Paul and VIN and every
and I ended up booking this movie I got
the part and and I'm like wow this is
really cool and we're gonna do all these
cars and then it got on set and it
became you know this crazy thing and
everyone's gonna be like oh it's gonna
be it's gonna be huge it's gonna be this
big moving I'm like no I just don't I
don't I don't think so I was just so
locked into this into this brain of mine
and then lo and behold it became like a
huge phenomenon and it changed my life
instantly and it taught me again that
you never never never no don't don't
turn down an audition don't don't be
silly you know and I was really silly
and I tell this story and not that I'm
so appreciative that I went in and I was
given that opportunity and andha it
changed my life forever forever so I
learned a valuable lesson then you know
just you know keep your mind open you
know appreciate what you have if it
comes when you're 19 if it comes when
you're 40 just appreciate that moment
one of my early jobs was on Fantasy
Island and I was among a retinue of
young women you know that were
surrounding this older man who was the
star the guest star of the show and so
we broke for lunch and one of the other
women I had lines this other woman
didn't have lines but she we were
walking to lunch and she was a goddess I
mean she was so beautiful and very sweet
and really lovely and we were just
talking and I liked her right away and
then she started to tell me about her
husband and immediately I got this
overwhelming sense of dread on her
behalf I mean I have chills now even
remembering it and he had she'd been
working at a Dairy Queen in Canada or
something and and he's he was older than
she and he spotted her and he saw what
she was and he got her into Playboy and
she had a you know Playboy centerfold
spot and and she had the more she
talked about him the creepier I felt
about this guy but you know we just met
each other what am I gonna say about her
husband you know you better watch out
for him and and then I learned that she
was with my agency and then about a week
or a month later two months later maybe
I'm walking with my agent to an audition
and he tells me that this woman just got
a part in a major motion picture now I
have been a classically trained actor
since I was 2 years old and she had just
blown into town now she was a goddess I
have to give you that in Hollywood you
know eats that up but I was so jealous I
couldn't believe it
I was just churning with envy inside and
resentment and and it would
oh it felt like it was awful and about 2
months after that I was going to New
York I had a play that I was taking to
New York that I wanted to shop around a
bit and I'm walking home and I see a
headline you know beauty queen slain and
I thought it was some you know Miss New
Jersey or something I didn't pay any
attention I called my agents to find out
what was going on if I should come her
earlier they said oh we're just so
worried we were just so upset about
Dorothy and I put on my best Beth I
tried my best to care and I went oh
really why and she said didn't you hear
her husband just shot her in the face
and murdered her because she was
drifting away from him and it was
Dorothy stratten who was the subject of
that film star 80 and even how you see
that I was so ashamed of myself for
begrudging her one moment of celebrity
or joy because I had no idea what lay
before her and I had no idea what she
went through to get that to get there to
her moment in the Sun and how dare I how
dare I
and that was I was more affected by what
what by her death and what it called up
in me then I was on my own grandfather
because I was so ashamed of my jealousy
Jackson I was dying to get his respect
probably you know I mean he's definitely
a great mentor you know only a second of
my grandfather you know but this man
knows everybody's lines you knows
everybody's lies he knows what the
camera wound what line and where he did
what and he knows everything it's really
amazing so I am in rehearsals mmm
rehearsals Samuel I know he was teaching
me less we've had this conversation
before so he's got these giant
monologues at the end of the film that
are actually much bigger than wouldn't
even ended up in the film and the
rehearsals he Kevin Reynolds like hey
you ready you guys ready to do this
scene yeah man let's let's do it and Sam
looks up he's like yeah man he throws
his scenes on the floor
he's got the big speeches anyway so I'm
I've holding my gun and then he just
like looks up at me got tears he can
control this I on this side too by the
way he can make this cry right now you
can make this cry he can hold them I
can't do that but he can so when I saw
him holding the tears and he literally
just put the pedal to the metal and I
thought oh my god I I don't know if I
can ever be that good sigh I just
remember uh just racing home racing home
and just delving as deeply as I could
just to get any ounce of respect from
him yeah he's a tough love kind of guy
he got really really really earned it
but I remember one scene where I thought
okay I now accept the destiny of me also
being a director it was on a hijacking
we were in the office off the ship Pulu
had a gun stuck to his back head and it
was just a test we didn't even we didn't
even want to shoot it was just a camera
test
how can we cover this but I could detect
that pilla was there we'd spent now a
month on the ship sailing in these
Indian Ocean surrounded by pirates so it
was real and suddenly I could see
Palouse here let's just go so I
whispered to her but let's shoot this
and it ended up with you calling your
wife live back in Denmark on the
satellite phone I was tapping that line
and doing the whole thing and it's not
in the script but you just went crazy
and attacked the pirate hmm and in doing
that you hit your head but I couldn't
see that so I just had and if you was on
the floor you know crying I know that
he's so fucking great wow this is not
acting this is real and then suddenly I
could see blood on the floor okay oh oh
we don't have special effects out today
what the fuck is going on
you know and I realized that the whole
thing from him attacking the pirate anon
was real and he bombed his head and he
was open yeah and there was so much
blood all over the place but I didn't
stop it because you know I thought oh
he's so pressing and after that I was
like okay I have to take control of
being a director I cannot risk the
security of people let's go let's let's
be let's be professional about this that
was cool
I was amazing see that and it became the
midpoint of that phone I think the
biggest satisfaction that I have is when
each each scene has what the scene is
about but then there's this little
nuance it has to do with what the
character is really going through and it
usually has to do with his this
motivation that he has and no one else
knows he's trying to get close to
someone he's trying to introduce someone
to someone it's not the obvious thing
and seeing Norman seeing Richard grab on
to that small nuance and bring it to
life and express it in some way was
incredibly satisfying to me because it's
as if he was revealing this secret about
what really goes through Norman's head
I remember him directing me I'm flashing
on when the early scenes was actually
the first scene that's in the movie
I'm approaching Dan Stevens in the park
and I got a deal I'm trying to convince
him but I remember we were doing the
shot as we as he moves away because he
basically does it no one wants anything
to do with this Norman or any Norman
it's it's how do you make them stop
without using losing your own dignity in
making them stop yeah and you see that a
lot with characters in this movie who
just they don't want have to say go away
leave me alone it's it's some level of
please enough
so I'm chasing I'm chasing we're doing a
Steadicam shot and he's saying remember
this direction was too you know maybe
you could just kind of Bob behind him
and try to get his attention well you're
coming behind and it was so I mean I got
it immediately what you were talking
about and that ended up informing much
of what I did in a film the sense of
peak peaking peaking over someone's
shoulder and just waving I'm still here
is hi seeing Richard Gere do that it's
incredibly satisfying and I got a call
from my agents when I landed in Houston
say they wanted to reroute me to New
Orleans that I'd been offered this role
in the Dallas buyers club but I needed
to be there the next day and I said
Mitchell he said he said in the first
place and he never does this he said say
yes I said do me a favor I'll read the
script on the next leg from Houston to
Birmingham and I'll call you when I land
but I got to get home I got to see my
kids and he said okay but they're gonna
turn you right around you're gonna go
back to New Orleans
and he's the last he said was to say yes
so because he knew that he knew the
project and when I got there because I
was drawn in a little bit late
but a lot was there were a lot of moving
parts and there's this wonderful crazy
french-canadian director Jean mark
vislay I adored working with him I'll be
forever grateful for the for the notes
that he gave me because he he gave my
character dimension that I might have
missed I was stepping in quickly to
something and but when I walked into the
into the hospital room the first time to
work with Matthew I was like when's he
coming in you know and he's of course
he's more than ready he's standing over
there but he had lost so much weight
that he was unrecognizable to me so so
we when we started the same I'm still
waiting for McConaughey to come in and
he's there and it you know it's one of
those things that kind of throw you in
the moment when you finally realize oh
oh we're going and you better catch up
so it actually helped me because we were
we were in the in the throws a bit
before I had an opportunity to get
nervous about it so I was doing a movie
called push years ago and chasse Palma
Terry was in the movie and in the movie
he kind of plays like my father figure
and we all know Chazz Palma Terry is a
great actor tall intimidating man very
very generous very nice so in this scene
I am supposed to come in and tell him
that I lost all this money and I need
help and I need I need it I needed him
to bail me out of this life-or-death
situation so I kept coming into the
scene I'm supposed to be crying and this
and I wasn't bringing in Pierhead
I was stinking up the room and I
couldn't get there and so all right
maybe you know take five or whatever I
come in goes what you say he grabs me
pulls me to him and goes slaps me across
the face wham like this the whole set
you can hear a pin drop and I was like I
started crying he goes what'd you say he
goes come here and he grabs me again
slaps me again and man's got hand
you know Wham I'm like oh my god and
then I started to cry and started to get
into it and before you know it I'm like
cut director yells cut he's like that's
amazing thank you so much and I go
outside and I ball cried and I cried I
cried because I just got my ass handed
to me by a football player in this
business right and I went inside and
Chazz he grabbed me and he pulled me in
and gave me a big huge hug and goes
don't take it personally kid he goes to
NATO slap me and if you go back and you
watch I think it was a Bronx Tale and in
a scene they're slapping each other or
DeNiro slash them or something like that
and they would keep doing that back and
forth until they actually got into the
scene so I felt it was a huge honor that
he trusted me enough to slap me and then
he told that Sid the story on Conan
because Conan was like do actors get
intimidated of you
he was like yeah and he started to tell
the story about how he slapped me and
but we got there so he was sensitive to
me and and and he was also being very
generous and helping me it wasn't about
him and I think that's something that we
need to do as actors is is is be
generous to the other actor because if
we both need to look good you know it's
not all about me and my coverage no like
we need to be generous to the other
actor we're gonna stand there and while
they're doing their coverage and give
them their lines because it's it's it's
the right thing to do do the work do the
work do the work
and it's funny cuz you go into certain
projects you know with the Ned Harris
like West world and then in this film as
well but I already won Ed's respect in
this film and in Westford I had not so
you know I called a few friends that had
worked with him just to find out a
little background on him and then um I
just studied really hard I studied
really hard to learn my lines
I studied hard to learn his lines just
in case he was like what's my line why
I'd be able to like I think I think you
say but uh maybe this is I don't know
you never know I was gonna take it like
he's got a navigate so I'm navigating
and um and he goes oh thanks partner
all right so I did that and then I
slammed the scene where my daughter my
wife gets killed
and then he came running over to me and
just pointing at me and filth in and for
all things like yes yes yes and he
fucking kicks me washed in like real
hard and he goes that's how you do it
and anybody walked away I was like I
hope that's gonna leave a mark
good at Harris did to me forget a good
job it's pretty rad
it was pretty awesome so that's how I
got his respect when it comes to playing
I really equate live music with live
theater and filmmaking with being in the
studio because you know it's a
controlled you know even in a case like
cop car which was you know a lot of
things having to do with elements and
I've really pared down crew and kids and
you know kids driving cars and guns and
all that kind of stuff you you you still
have take two and it is a relatively
controlled kind of situation that's what
the music studios like you need you can
do another pass on a vocal you know you
can you know put overdub something on
it's it's kind of like the same editing
process sure in the tour bus experience
tour bus experience is tour bus
experience is sort of unlike anything
that I've done in the film's up because
I don't tend to share our dressing room
with nine other smelly for a month at a
time generally even if my dressing room
is small I'm still not sharing it with
nine guys and sleeping in a bunk and you
know all that comes with that the thing
is like there are people who are doing
all of these things kind of for you like
we wrote a script and then our producers
I imagine
got that in the hands of either your
daughter or your representation probably
my daughter and then you had the chance
to receive runs everything I don't know
what's going on we were fortunate in
that one of our producers as friends
with Chelsea so it's that right right
that is correct but we could still do
the role play okay let's do it here here
so here's what it had been like hey hey
Billy over at Lonely Island can you get
this or will over at Lord and Miller can
you get this script over to Chelsea
Hamel to potentially get it to Mark
Hamill we'll do our best okay thank you
and I imagine you get a phone call or an
email send me a deal memo I don't care
about the script I just want to know how
much I'm can make do I get any back-end
it's believe me at this point in my
career
the script is everything well you know
honestly like that's something that I
was the most nervous about when I read
the script and we Adam and I spoke we
said you know we're gonna wear these
prosthetics I actually was not nervous
but I mean obviously I was on some level
to wear this prosthetic but the applying
of the prosthetic was where my mind went
to first like what are the steps that go
into that because I don't want to make
anyone feel like they regret their life
yeah and and it's just you know and I
had my wife like talk to me before like
what do i do how do I anything I should
do like you know they it's it's a lot of
glue and so you just got to make sure
that it's um yeah it's a wonderful it
was a wonderful time sure very
delicately it was a strange time yeah
well there's a strange time in my life
and then as we were getting closer to
shooting we got luckily got Jason to
agree to do it
I couldn't believe that I got this
opportunity oh we were so lucky to get I
had a designer thing where I was like
literally this is too good there's
there's gotta be some catch that they're
there miss seeing some I was soaks I
couldn't believe the catch was you would
have to yes